Okay, I really hope you enjoyed this lesson and
that you learned a lot about different kinds of professions,
you can use genetics with. One profession we learned
about is that of a Bioethicist. Bioethicists are critical in
helping us create new ethical standards in medical science
and research. They frequently debate issues like gene patenting and
they also help us to interpret important legal issues
such as GINA or the Genetic Information Non-discrimination Act. Another
important profession uses genetics, but which you
don't need an advanced degree, or even a
specialized degree in genetics for, is a director
of clinical operations. A director of clinical operations
designs and manages clinical trials. And they
also use information from pharmacogenetics to help inform
their decisions about designing and managing those clinical
trials. Now, another profession, specifically a human geneticist.
Deals with hardcore genetic questions. And their research sometimes
contributes to clinical trials that are carried out by
director of clinical operations. Now human geneticists find genetic
factors resulting in various traits. Which we've learned about in
lesson one, as well as simple traits in lesson
eight and complex traits in lesson nine. They also
study gene expression which we learned about in lesson
two, three, and four. And a human geneticist in particular
will frequently make use of a pedigree. Another profession that
also uses pedigrees is a genetic counselor. Remember a pedigree
is useful because it denotes family relationships as well as
whether or not you're affected by a particular trait. So
it can reveal an inheritance pattern of a trait you're
interested in. And genetic counselors frequently help with family planning.
Couples who want to have a child, and they're very
interested in knowing what the future of that child might
be, health or otherwise. Another profession that uses
genetics is a computational biologist. And a computational
biologist is going to use copious amounts of
computer science coding. They're usually specialists in computers,
specifically computer science or coding. Who also learn
enough Biology, to apply what they know in
computer science and coding. Now, one of the
specific examples we talked about in our course,
is how a computational biologist in particular,
can actually derive an IBD score. Which is
an identity by distance score. Which we know
can indicate relatives and ancestry, which we learned
about in lesson seven and 11. But another
important profession we discussed. A genetic genealogist also
uses IBD or identity by decent. And other
kinds of information to help find relatives and
ancestry for individuals. If you have any
interest in learning more about these professions
and others you should check out the
instructor's notes on this page for career resources.